only four years ago but it seems like a
lifetime away so much has changed in
British politics since of 2015 general
election
grexit has transformed the political
landscape bringing in new banners and
perhaps at this election new MPs - but
it's also strained our politics to a
breaking point and is pushing some
people away what's been surprising and
worrying is the number of women who
joined Parliament in this decade who are
deciding to call it a day in the prime
of their careers let me show you some of
them there's this woman Seema Kennedy 45
years old the former assistant to Teresa
may then there's a sovereign cabinet
minister Nicky Morgan just 47 years old
former Home Secretary amber rod former
government ministers Mims Davis and
Sarah Newton both deciding to quit
Parliament all together and then on the
Labour benches you've got Gloria de
Pierrot and you've got the former
conservative turned Lib Dem Heidi Allen
both women citing toxic levels of abuse
as a reason for quitting politics this
former Minister won't be standing either
another woman from the moderate wing of
the Conservatives on her way out the his
two colleagues you know what were you
surprised I was saw that Nicki Asafa
cabinet minister had decided to call it
quits I was really shocked and at that
moment um I thought I'm gonna fight on
I'm definitely gonna fight on too many
of us are going from our side of the
party to many good women are going and
that was you know the only last Thursday
so you know my decision was made just
after that really but out of step with
her local party over brexit Margate
James decided not to fight on she's not
even sure she can vote conservative
anymore were you very conservative in
the next election I would like to
reserve judgment to see who my
association selects to replace me I am
hopeful that I will be voting
conservative in Stourbridge as long as
they select somebody really decent she's
a victim of brexit warfare this is not
what others signed up for I don't think
that's that is what a lot of women want
their contribution to be you know just
on one-sided tribal aggressive form
forms of politics I don't think that's
necessary I don't think it's desirable
and I don't think it suits the majority
of women's style a hostile environment
that needs to change there's no need to
talk about politics in terms of war and
all of this it's just so unnecessary it
isn't a game
it's not a war and we need to dial all
that stuff down for all these MPs
tomorrow is their last day in this place
record numbers of women now sit on these
benches but many here not sure if that
will still be true on the other side of
this snap election bathra be Sky News
Westminster